michelle is with us rachelle's in
chicago hi rochelle welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hello thanks for taking the call um i am
50 years old a probation officer i make
50k a year
i have 182 and student loans 32
000 in collections i have no savings and
i'm trying to figure out should i give
up my dreams of getting a house
how old are you again 50.
man you sound so young 5-0 yeah 182
000 what's your degree in i have a
my bachelor's is in um criminal justice
and i have a master's a mba with a
concentration in human resources
what are you making a year rochelle i
only make 50.
50k a year and you're 50 years old okay
so you're dramatically underemployed
giving your education
yes
yeah so you have a career path problem
for one thing
no i'm not giving up a dream of winning
period and if part of the definition of
winning is buying a house
i'm not giving up that dream but one of
the things we ask ourselves when we're
setting goals
around here is um what has to be true
that's not true now
yeah in order to get there okay
so we have 182 000 32 of which is
already screwed up
yeah right in collections and so we've
got this ridiculously expensive degree
and now we got to use it yeah so what
has to be true is your income has to
come up that's what has to be true
and then as it comes up we're going to
put you on a tight budget where you have
no life
for a couple years and you clean this
whole freaking mess
up and uh by the time you're 60 you're
100
uh debt free and you own a house yeah
yeah
and and here's the thing rochelle you
have to tell yourself
i'm not gonna give up okay so stop
asking yourself
am i giving up on my dreams no you're
not giving up on your dreams what you're
doing
is you're just preparing yourself for
your dreams
right now it may seem like it's late
because it's you are
50 but that's not late that's not late
at all you know so what i'll go ahead
and do is just use your dreams to feel
the fire where you are right now
but you have to really get hard you
don't have any time to play
you have an mba right yes
and you live in chicago yes yeah you
need to be making double what you're
making
right exactly exactly or
would you even consider moving yeah
if if you can't land something you need
to move yeah but the point is
that that um you you have overpaid for
the degree
and then under utilized the degree
yeah in creating incomes that make sense
that makes sense and that that's caused
you to feel overwhelmed and
it feels like a crap been beat out of
you right
exactly yeah like you're stuck yeah and
so uh we're about to unstick this get
some dynamite and light it rochelle
where did you go to school i got to ask
that question i'm a school guy
i just want to know i went to aurora
university in aurora illinois
and i got both degrees at the same place
okay
hang on we're going to send you a copy
of ken coleman's book
proximity principle to help you get
going and you call us back and we'll
talk to you anytime we're going to be
your biggest cheerleaders you're going
to make it
but it's an income issue